what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so I absolutely love what Joshua
Williamson is doing with the flash and
again we're getting caught up on a lot
of this DC rebirth stuff since we've
been slacking off so bad but Joshua
Williams as flashes is solid I mean it's
amazing honestly I don't really think
that I've seen this kind of development
since the mark Wade run and again I
never really read mark Wade's flash when
it came out it wasn't until after the
fact that I went back as sort of reading
it but I know what Mark Waid did he
expanded the flash mythos in a lot of
ways grabbing character is rolling them
back in different things like that
providing new origin stories creating
the Speed Force and Jeff John's really
built on a lot of that stuff you know
but mark Wade's run is kind of like the
definitive run of the flash when it
comes to his character but Joshua
Williamson is doing incredible things
with DC rebirth now remember this all
really comes out of the origin the new
origin of eobard thawne and that's one
of the funny things because when it
comes to coming with characters
especially when they're really really
popular changes can be very polarizing
take for example the name
Thanos for example you know Marvel
Comics it was revealed that his real
name was Deon and it was kind of funny
cuz I got into a Twitter discussion with
someone and they were just like well
this is just you know they didn't really
care for it too much they were like I
imagine the black order is gonna be
going on you know going around and
calling him like you know Deon and I'm
like what would make you think that like
why wouldn't they just keep calling him
Fanus honestly I would see people like
learning what his real name is calling
him that and then Thanos kills them and
it's like no my name is Stannis I mean I
could easily see it playing out that way
it's kind of a interesting scenario but
people who really really like particular
characters have a hard time dealing with
change when it comes to those characters
but in fact your mains it is really cool
because with eobard thawne's a new
origin it was basically rooted in this
idea that he idolized Barry Allen much
like his original origin story he
travelled back in time to see Barry
Allen just like his original origin
story the difference was that there was
a point where Barry ended up in the
future where he barred Thawne lived and
you know yeah boy I thought it basically
copied the powers of Barry and then
Barry trained him on how to become the
flash and when the eobard thawne had
gone back in time he had this very
particular moment that he and Barry
shared only to turn around and see Barry
sharing that same moment with Wally West
and the result was that a bit of
jealousy kicked in you know he kind of
became you know really angry at the
whole scenario and then swore vengeance
on him just because he felt betrayed and
it was a very human kind of reaction to
that scenario as opposed to I'm eobard
thawne and I went to the past and
time-travel work my mind and I learned I
was destined to be a villain it drove me
insane you know that origin is very much
a fantasy origin is reminiscent of
something you would see in the 1950s but
the whole idea was
with that new origin berry and eobard
ended up you know battling one another
and berry was thrown into the negative
Speed Force basically this the Speed
Force that was generated or at least a
variant of the Speed Force that's been
generated and is really only used by
eobard thawne and the result is that
somewhat corrupted his powers now that
origin story really sort of ended
ambiguous like we didn't really know
what the full effects of Barry Allen's
powers were at least what his new powers
were after he had come into conflict
with eobard thawne and this really picks
up with that that there are
after-effects there's a new level of
power that Barry has and he's not really
sure how to control it not only that
he's almost kind of like a hybrid you
know Barry Allen when he first became
the flash ever you know from the first
time he started running basically sort
of generating the Speed Force and it's
almost like this pure version of the
Speed Force where asked eobard thawne
generated the negative Speed Force and
he tapped into that and so for Barry he
still got access to the Speed Force but
combined with it are the effects of the
negative Speed Force so really this is
uncharted water we've never really seen
anything like this before it's kind of
interesting because at this point
Barry's running on this sort of hybrid
form of energy and the result is that of
course we end up you know seeing the the
reintroduction of a character named
shrapnel now shrapnel was a guy who was
created by Erik Larsen and he appeared
back in 1988 and I want to say he was a
Doom Patrol villain but to be honest I
don't really know a lot about his
character
um I know he's kind of like he's got
organic metal more or less and he could
fire them in the form of you know little
pieces of shrapnel hence the name but I
never really looked too much into him
and truth this is actually the first
introduction I had to his character and
I went back and did a little bit of
research but there's really not a whole
lot there there's no real origin story
for him he showed up and do patrol he
fought them for a little while he was
shanghaied on to the Suicide Squad just
different things like that little
tidbits he's one of those characters one
of those villains that was introduced
and then was just kind of free-floating
but the long and short or I guess the
common theme for shrapnel as it he was
always kind of like a villain for hire
his services were always available for
anybody who wanted to use them but the
problem with Barry is that with this
negative Speed Force that he wields it
basically emits like these massive
bursts of energy from time to time and a
lot of it seems to be tied to his
emotional state and so where he's
chasing down these criminals who you
know basically robbed uh you know
location and stole a whole bunch of
stuff what he's leaving in his path is
this massive amount of destruction
because this negative Speed Force is
letting off energy that he doesn't
really know how to cope with yet now on
the surface again we would kind of
expect that there would be some measure
of control here or it would be a
scenario or it would be like well why
doesn't he just control it but remember
cave to the original speed force when
Mariana first became the flash back in
1956 he didn't really know how to
control his powers we needed to a degree
because the story somewhat called for it
but over the years after his original
introduction by Julius Schwartz and so
on there was a lot of development there
at the time those stories were being
written our characters weren't
necessarily as grounded as they are now
and so massive amounts of destruction in
the wake of Barry Allen running around
didn't really exist but going into the
post-crisis landscape a lot of that kind
of remained the same just because things
sort of worked themselves out that way
there wasn't really a reason or wasn't
really a drive to show this path of
destruction where cities are being
obliterated because Barry Allen Speed
Force was letting off energy that he
didn't know how to use I mean the Speed
Force didn't and didn't exist back then
so it was just very can run super fast
and so because of that by the Thomas
Speed Force was introduced
you know Barry had already had a well
amount of control over his powers and so
he was able to basically negate the
effects of the Speed Force in outward
momentum and the destruction of things
and so what this does is kind of bring a
little bit of tangible nature into that
I kind of build on the general
acceptance that Barry knows how to use
us and use us powers and there's no real
destruction and then saying well now
he's got a new set of powers and you
know a hybrid source of energy he
doesn't really know how to use them
effectively and it's cool because this
almost sets Barry back to square one
it's almost like Barry's becoming the
flash for the very first time and using
his powers for the very first time and
not really sure how they work when
you've had so much control over your
abilities to suddenly be thrown into a
circumstance where you have no control
over your powers is actually pretty
terrifying now again because of the fact
that focus is so much on Barry himself
and focuses on the aftermath of his
actions and you know the idea that his
powers are somewhat growing beyond his
control
it is cool because this creates a kind
of ripple effect throughout the entirety
of his life because his whole foundation
is being shattered at the moment you
know he's going to this existential
crisis and it's impacting his friends as
impacting his relationships also lest we
forget in the aftermath of eobard
thawne's new origin and the fact that
you know all these events would take
place with the kids of Barry Allen and
the fact that they would grow up to
become bill a villains different things
like that
this basically set in motion the idea
that iris West doesn't want to have
anything to do with him and so his life
is just kind of breaking down in front
of his eyes and is putting him in this
crazy psychological state because he's
doing what he can to cope with it but
he's also in uncharted waters here and
so again you know here's our connection
more or less with sane the guy who runs
the central city forensics lab is making
that extremely strenuous you know his
emotional
stayed again feeding in the fact that
he's getting so irritated chasing down
criminals he's getting angry all the
time and again that's the nature of the
flash they sure the flash is not to be
angry it's to maintain a level head but
with these news powers that doesn't
really feed into it it's I'm so tired of
all these criminals running around
Central City and committing all these
crimes and just flying off the handle
not only that when shrapnel shows up of
course Barry Allen chasing these guys
down and so on and so forth offers a
measure of a distraction so that when
shrapnel arrives suddenly is this masked
a dispersal of metal all over the place
and literally Barry Allen's is kind of a
bystander and everybody thinks that
Barry's actions led to the death of all
these different criminals and that's a
crazy thing is because now his reckless
behavior not analyzing the the core
situation as well as everything else he
could go on around him it's all coming
home to roost because as far as he's
concerned
had he not created a momentary
distraction had he not lapsed for second
grabbed the criminals and just whisked
them off to the police department trout
no wouldn't been able to make his move
and shrapnel wouldn't have killed all
those guys now the fight between Barry
and shrapnel is actually pretty
straightforward in the sense for the
most part Barry is able to use his
momentum to get the upper hand but this
is when another byproduct of his of his
new abilities comes to bear when it's
the power to let off this massive amount
of energy and instead of just subdue a
shrapnel and taking him to jail he blows
him up and so that's the that's the
crazy thing here I mean ultimately
shrapnel can reconstitute himself he's
not dead forever but it's interesting
because his role as a superhero in the
greater DC Pantheon is in flux he
doesn't know if he's a good guy he
doesn't know if he's a bad guy what's
also happening here is that under the
scenes behind the current there is
someone going through and stealing blood
samples out of Central City and so
things just kind of keep going and going
like they always have now again the way
that joshua williamson writes the story
is designed to basically seem like
central city is spiraling out of control
but it's not he of central city is
progressing the way it always did
there's always villains they always do
bad things there's always some mystery
to solve
always some crime that takes place and
the whole precipice of the flash story
is that Barry Allen is fast enough in
order to solve those problems but then
when he has to basically step back and
say but I'm not really sure how my
powers are impacting things and I have
to be careful well then it's basically
slowing himself down and that's why it's
so interesting because what this throws
into sharp relief is the idea that
Barry's powers became a crutch more so
than anything else his ability to move
at SuperSpeed men he was always a step
ahead but
that he has to slow down he's running at
the same pace as the curve and so
instead of being able to be so far ahead
and being able to move so fast and pick
and choose which things deserve his
attention certainly some massive influx
of stimulus and everything requires his
attention because he's got relationships
that are crashing down those crimes that
are being committed and blood samples
are missing and it's all these things
that are happening is this huge crisis
going on in the life of Barry Allen and
that's why it's so cool now the other
half of this is that because these blood
samples belong or at least have been
stored inside the Central City forensics
department whatever you want to call it
of course it looks bad on you know Singh
the guy who heads this whole department
and so on and so forth and of course you
know Singh it basically put together a
task force of sorts of Barry woman and
Kristin and a couple other people in
order to investigate the whole thing the
problem with this is that Barry's
feeling of being almost inept as the
flash which is to say his inability to
function the way he always did and this
lack of control over his own life almost
kind of leads him just kind of be like
well then we need to go focus on this on
our own and under normal circumstances
he would whiz through all this stuff and
he would grab these guys you know so on
and so forth but notice this it's
moments where he's like well I don't
need my powers to be able to save these
guys I don't need my powers in order to
be able to get these guys to safety now
in truth he doesn't I mean there seems
to be no imminent danger here I mean
there's just some bodies who are lying
on the ground inside this you know
forensics analysis storage office and
they all seem to be alive or at the very
least you know seem to be struggling
some you know some are dead but the idea
is okay you know let's grab these guys
who were mostly you know survive and
let's take them out there it's
recklessness under normal circumstances
Barry would just be like all right let's
get him out and he would use his powers
and just where's each one of these guys
out of the building to a pretty safe
location the problem is that because
he's being a bit reckless here someone
set the lab on fire and then suddenly
he's got to get these guys out as fast
as you can but then he can't because he
simply collapses again it's a bit of
recklessness here you know of course
Barry does live I mean you know he kind
of wakes often and of course he knows
the whole place is basically being you
know hosed down by firemen and that kind
of stuff but notice this Barry Allen
starts to get angry he starts to get
reckless again and that's the funny
thing about that with Barry Allen's new
abilities being tied into his emotional
state it almost seems like one feeds the
other the negative Speed Force
inherently brings out the negative
attributes of Barry Allen in turn Barry
Allen's emotions flare up at a negative
fashion and feed the negative Speed
Force and it just kind of feeds into
itself over and over and over again this
leads to a massive argument kind of an
explosion of emotions between Barry and
everybody else in the crime lab and
really kind of brings out all these
feelings that berries seems to have been
harboring for quite some time I mean you
know he basically yells at Singh and
says look I'm tired of this father
figure tough love crap that you've been
pulling and you know suddenly Singh is
saying things like I don't understand
why iris dealt with you like this and
you know sure run off when you're needed
and then suddenly you know it's you know
Forrest you're the lab mascot you don't
really ever do anything and it's
basically throwing all this vitriol and
all this anger and all this hatred at
everybody around him now this is what's
so interesting about this is because
following this whole scenario when he
storms off and he just tells Singh to
fire up he's met by Kristin and this is
very very important despite one of the
most important parts of the story and it
wouldn't seem like it is on the surface
on the surface it would seem easily
dismissive Kristin sits down with Barry
and tells him about how her parents had
died in a car wreck and that her sister
wasn't really able to cope with the
situation and so her sister just kind of
fell down into this self-destructive
pattern and eventually took her life but
along the way she stopped talking to
Kristin she wouldn't answer phone call
she wouldn't answer text while on the
surface this is Kristin basically
displaying this concern that Barry's
falling down a self-destructive pattern
and much like Kristin's sister may end
up taking his own life the important
thing about this is this hearkens on the
nature of what it means to just beat
hist off all the time look at the real
world and I imagine if I say hey like
what do you think about what do you
think that like the u.s. at the moment
people will start poking around with all
those terrible things aw man this is
happening and that's happening you know
politics and all that kind of stuff but
then at the same time it's like yeah but
I mean there are organizations that
exist to feed the homeless
and there's Habitat for Humanity
building homes for people who can't
afford them on their own for all the
terrible things that happen there's some
wonderful and amazing things that happen
out there it's so easy to deviate
towards the negative it's so easy to
deviate and just say everything sucks
and there are people who will just do
that there are people who are just be
like all I'm ever gonna focus on is the
bad stuff and for those folks the
easiest thing to do is to just kind of
feel bad for them and then just go and
enjoy your life go be happy life's too
short to be miserable why would you
focus on being angry all the time I mean
all you're gonna do is push people away
and I can say that because I've been
there I mean let's talk about this for a
second the life of Rob when I was in my
early 20s I started a job that I hated I
gave up my weekends working second and
third shift I was off you know on some
of the weekdays but nobody ever goes out
on weekdays I basically ended up losing
a lot of relationships with my friends
I've worked Christmases I've worked
Thanksgivings when my family was eating
dinner
Thanksgiving Day at the table I was at
work when I had family that were opening
Christmas presents on Christmas Day I
was at work I got home and opened them
man but there were so many birthdays and
Thanksgivings and Christmases that I
missed out on and it made me a miserable
human being and you would be surprised
how fast people walk away from you
French you've had for years he be amazed
how fast they walk away when all you do
is spew vitriol and anger and you just
become a miserable human being you just
steadily push everyone away and that's
what's happening with Barry at the
moment because of the fact that he's so
pissed off that he's so angry and this
negative speed force is impacting every
facet of his life all he's doing is
pushing people away
and that's why stories like this why
Joshua Winston's writing is so cool it's
not those old school come about they're
tangible they're real they're relatable
they impact us in different ways because
we can take moments either entire story
arcs or moments from a comic and say yep
I've been there brother
like I've been down that road you know
and that's that's the funny thing
because you know that's that's why we as
fans like comic books you know it's in a
lot of ways allows for a measure of
relatability
and while Barry Allen's not real if he
was you know when it's like man dude I
have no idea how to cope with this I
don't know where I am I would say hey
look like once upon a time there was a
man walking down the road and he fell
into a hole in the ground fell into a
sewer and he's just sitting there
screaming he says help help help you
know a doctor walks by the doctor writes
him a prescription throws it down in the
hall healer the walk doctor keeps on
going even after that you know the guy
screams help help help you know when a
priest comes by and the guy says priest
can you get me out of here and the
priest writes to him you know I guess it
was like a prayer and then you know
keeps on going on and then finally a
friend walks by and the guy says dude
you know Steve can you help me out can
you help me out and the Steve's like
yeah man then he climbs down into the
hole and the guy's like dude what are
you doing man now we're both trapped
down here and Steve says yeah but I've
been here before and I know the way out
that's what makes this thing so cool is
because it creates this kind of
relatability you know with these with
these characters so in any event what we
end up doing here is finding out that
the person who's been stealing all these
blood samples is the guy who works down
in the crime lab named name Ramsey but
the guy's been going through and just
kind of you know doing his thing and he
has been stealing all these different
blood samples some that belong to normal
people and some that belong to
metahumans and the reason why he's been
doing this is because he's a hemophiliac
and what this means is that his blood
blood can't clot now the fact that his
blood cannot clot basically means that
when he was raised by his parents he was
not allowed to do anything dangerous he
wasn't allowed to go out and play with
kids and that's what makes us so
interesting is because what
you're a kid you don't really care about
like getting hurt when you're a kid you
don't really think about consequences
you're just like let's go play you know
and then you run out into the jungle gym
and then if you're like me you decide
it's a great idea to go swinging off of
a tree branch even though it just
finished raining because of Seattle and
it rains all the time and then you fall
and you brace your you put your arm
straight out to brace your fall and then
you dislocate your elbow you're not
thinking about any of the consequences
your does out having a great time but
it's because of the fact that kids don't
really think of the end result of their
actions that his parents really kept him
on a short leash if your blood can't
clot then all it's gonna take is for you
to go out play on the jungle gym and
then cut yourself and then suddenly
you're just bleeding out all over the
place you will bleed to death that's the
reality of his life and that's exactly
what happened you know he basically just
cut himself and he started bleeding
everywhere it took the arrival of an
ambulance and doctors to provide him
with the means necessary in order to to
basically heal himself I imagine
platelets honestly I don't know what
kind of treatment goes in to dealing
with someone who's a hemophiliac and
cuts themselves I mean obviously there's
treatment there and I'm sure I could
look it up on Google but the fact
remains that because of the fact that he
was raised in such a helpless manner the
goal is to keep himself from being
helpless and so what he'd been doing is
he'd basically been taking blood from
different you know metahumans that have
been arrested by the flash and their
blood had been dropped off for samples
so they could either learn how their
power works so they could find a means
to basically curtail their powers and
Ramsey had been taking it is actually
pretty genius because what Ramsey had
been doing was taking his knowledge of
how blood work functions taking his
knowledge from the medical profession
and Medical School blending them
together and saying how can I use the
blood of these metahumans in order to
make myself more powerful and so what he
did is he essentially made himself
indestructible and it's cool because
what Ramsey's also doing is learning
about his own powers now not only is he
invertible he can also control the blood
and other people and that's what he did
with up with the flash Barry out is you
know during the instance when the room
was set on fire and the flash passed out
Ramsey had basically manipulated his
blood for succour to coagulate and
limited the amount of oxygen going to
his brain and then in turn like force
him to pass out it's kind of cool but
the fact remains here that Ramsey kind
of rechristen stuff as blood work now
this also requires you know him to
basically learn how to control his
abilities and see how his powers
function and the reason for this is that
where flash runs around and tries to
stop Ramsey as best he can the I guess
increase in Ramsey's veins so to speak
or the various tendrils that he sends
out those are relative to how fast his
blood is pumping and so the more
powerful the more amped up
he becomes the faster is blood pumps and
so he basically begins to kind of
increase in mass and he's not really
paying attention to what he's doing now
eventually gets to the point where he's
basically just kind of like this giant
amorphous blob of just stuff like you
know just blood and vessels and
different things like that and it is
interesting because what Barry actually
does is he just kind of comes to terms
with everything he's done so far and
that's that's one of the coolest things
here it's very basically sitting down
and saying look I know where you're
coming from
like you are the way you are because you
felt helpless your entire life and you
didn't want to feel helpless anymore you
want it to be a person who could go out
and just do normal things not even
become a superhero not even become a
villain a person who could just go out
and do normal things a person who could
stop living in like a clean room
containment space and just have a normal
life and now that you finally have it
you're basically being stopped by a hero
so Barry's answer is I'm not here to
basically shut you down entirely I'm
here to give you the help that you need
you want a normal life I want you to
have a normal life this is a direct this
is a direct result of the life you've
lived and so I will do everything I can
to try to make life better for you and
when Barry gets in and he gets this
little brief glimpse of a moment to stop
the growth of Ramsey he literally uses
his power and his kind of issues a jolt
like a defibrillator and essentially
slows it down to the point that he stops
growing as fast as he is and returns
into a normal state it's kind of
interesting the problem with this is
that this is a bit of recklessness
because where Barry says I will get you
that you don't get you help the best I
can instead of taking him aside and
saying okay look let's train you in the
use of your abilities let's train you in
the use of your powers instead he's like
all right now you're under arrest and
throws him over to the cops the problem
with this was that the only evidence
Barry had was torched in a file room and
Barry who walked in on ramsey who
basically ended up becoming bloodwork
and so because of this it's one of those
things where it's basically the word of
vary against the word of ramsey now of
course this all comes to a head when
Kristin comes running up and basically
provides you know digital evidence to
indicate to illustrate that Ramsey who
is actually blood work he was stealing
those blood samples and you know for
whatever reason trying to make himself
into some great character of course
again Kristin doesn't know the back side
of the story in terms of Ramsey being a
hemophiliac and so on and so forth but
the problem with this is that Singh has
really had it up to here with Barry's
recklessness and Barry's actions and
that's what's kind of interesting about
this is because what we would think is
that when this story concludes okay
everything's fine and then Barry
apologizes to sing and sing apologizes
to Barry and said hey man it's all cool
don't worry about it managers you know
things go on instead it's not like that
sings response is I'm
basically you know I'm tired of
everything that you've done so far and
so we're gonna cut you loose you know
you are going to go work in iron Heights
and Chris and you're gonna go with it
and that's it now in terms of why this
is done there is a bigger picture going
on here but Barry's basically being
removed from the whole Central City
forensics department and being sent to
iron Heights penitentiary it's almost
like he's being shuffled off to the corn
fields because Singh doesn't necessarily
want to fire him he just doesn't want to
have to deal with him anymore
and so in response to this is really an
effort by Barry to kind of get his life
back on track to a degree you know one
to focus on the nature of his powers try
to find a way to control them the other
half of this is that he wants to walk
away Barry wants to quit you know if
being the flash means that him running
around cities is going to leave massive
amounts of destruction if him being the
flash or these new powers means that his
emotional state is tied into the use of
his powers and he's routinely pushing
people away then why even worry about it
at all and so where he goes to kind of
spy on iris West
of course Kid Flash shows up says what
are you doing here we don't want to have
anything to do with you
stay away Barry's responses I'm not here
to necessarily fight with you or
anything like that
I came here because I knew you would be
watching and so what I want to do is
give you my ring I quit I'm done being
the flash I want to go live a normal
life now this is this is a great moment
because Wally West responds or at least
you know the new Wally West response is
yeah but you trained me on how to use my
powers when my powers first emerged when
they first popped up I didn't know how
they worked they were dangerous I was
reckless
I was doing stupid things and I
shouldn't been doing I was unable to
bridge the gap between the life that I
used to live as a carefree kid and the
life that I have to live now as a kid
with powers and responsibilities you
know kind of a tribute to spider-man
there and so the result is that because
you took me under your wing and you
trained me on how to use my powers then
I'll do the same you know and this is
interesting because Wally West is no
Barry Allen he hasn't had his powers for
nearly as long he doesn't even have the
same kind of mastery of his powers as
Barry Allen does but it does introduce a
cool scenario because what we get is
this role reversal we basically get the
new Wally West training Barry Allen on
how to use his new abilities on how to
use his new powers but with that being
said guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end if you are new here to come as
explain make sure you guys are the sub
button to become part of the robb cork
if you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
peace
[Music]
you